In October, 2003, a guy was brought into the psychiatric emergency room at Bellevue Hospital in New York City. Dr. Joel Gold was the chief attending psychiatrist that day and saw him.
2003年10月，一名男子被送往纽约贝尔维尤医院的精神科急诊室。乔尔·戈德医生是当天的主治精神科医生，并负责接诊了他。
He felt that his life was essentially a reality show, that he's been recorded for years, that everyone in his life was an actor reading from a script. And he came to New York essentially to test this hypothesis.
他觉得自己的生活本质上是一场真人秀，他多年来一直被录像，生活中的每个人都是照着剧本演戏的演员。他来到纽约，本质上是为了验证这一假设。
He thought that maybe 9/11 was faked just to get a reaction out of him on reality TV.
他认为“9·11”事件可能是伪造的，只是为了在真人秀上看到他的反应。
And if he came to New York and if the World Trade Centers were still standing, he would know that that was in fact the case. If in fact they had been destroyed, then he would admit that perhaps he was delusional.
如果他来到纽约，发现世贸中心大厦依然矗立，他就会知道事实的确如此。如果它们确实已经被摧毁，那么他会承认自己可能产生了妄想。
But once he got  to New York, instead of visiting the Twin Towers, he walked into the United Nations and asked for asylum-- asylum from a TV show that was filming him without his consent 24 hours a day, which, you know, is how he ended up in Bellevue.
但当他到达纽约后，他没有去参观双子塔，而是走进联合国寻求庇护——寻求避开一个在他不知情的情况下每天24小时拍摄他的电视节目，这就是他最终被送进贝尔维尤医院的原因。
Dr. Gold didn't think much of this. People show up at Bellevue with lots of weird delusions all the time. And then a few months later, another guy walks in with the same idea-- that he was being filmed 24/7 and broadcast around the world. And the second guy, like the first one, mentioned a film-- the 1998 movie, The Truman Show .
戈德医生对此没太在意。人们总是带着各种奇怪的妄想出现在贝尔维尤。几个月后，又有一个人带着同样的想法走了进来——他觉得自己被24小时全天候拍摄并向全球直播。和第一个人一样，第二个人也提到了1998年的电影《楚门的世界》。
Both of them named The Truman Show by name. They said my life is like The Truman Show .
他们两个人都提到了《楚门的世界》这部电影。他们说，我的生活就像《楚门的世界》。
Truman is played by Jim Carrey. He's filmed all day every day on a program that is broadcast to billions of people around the globe. His wife, his best friend-- everybody around him is an actor. Everybody knows this is a TV show but him, until one day he starts to seek clues that make him suspicious.
楚门由金·凯瑞扮演。他每天每时每刻都在一个向全球数十亿人广播的节目中被拍摄。他的妻子、他最好的朋友——他身边的每个人都是演员。除了他自己，每个人都知道这是一场电视节目，直到有一天，他开始寻找让他产生怀疑的线索。
And just to be clear, you're not saying that The Truman Show necessarily triggered this. Like, people watch The Truman Show , and suddenly something in their brain snaps.
顺便问一下，你并不是说《楚门的世界》必然是触发点。比如，人们看了《楚门的世界》，然后大脑中有什么东西突然断裂了。
Yeah, exactly. On the contrary, I think it's just-- when people are becoming psychotic, things feel a little bit unusual, a bit odd. But what would explain all of this weirdness? And perhaps if you've seen the movie and that's kicking around in your head, you might say, yes, this is it. This is what's happening to me.
是的，正是这样。相反，我认为只是——当人们开始出现精神病症状时，事情会让人感觉有点不同寻常，有点古怪。但什么能解释所有这些奇怪的事情呢？也许如果你看过这部电影，而且这个想法一直在你脑海里盘旋，你可能会说，没错，就是这样。这就是我正在经历的事情。
If your psychosis includes both paranoia and a sense that you are very, very important-- what psychiatrists call grandiosity-- 30 years ago, you might think that the CIA or the KGB is watching you all the time. These days you have another possible explanation-- reality TV.
如果你的精神病症状包括偏执和一种自认为非常非常重要的感觉——精神病学家称之为自大——那么30年前，你可能会认为中央情报局或克格勃一直在监视你。而如今，你有另一种可能的解释——真人秀。
A few months later, a third patient showed up with the same delusion, and a few months after that a fourth. Dr. Gold started calling it "The Truman Show Delusion." He's just written a book about it with his brother Ian called Suspicious Minds . In one case in the book, a patient-- super-smart guy, an academic, very altruistic-- believed that he was part of an elaborate game show, and the world was watching him and betting on everything that he did.
几个月后，第三位患有同样妄想的病人出现了，几个月后又出现了第四位。戈德医生开始称之为“楚门秀妄想”。他刚刚和他的兄弟伊恩合著了一本关于此的书，名为《多疑的心》。书中有一个案例，一位病人——非常聪明、学术型、非常无私——相信自己正参与一场精心设计的游戏节目，全世界都在观看他，并对他所做的一切进行下注。
And this was a really fun thing that everyone would be doing online. And the monies collected would go to charities all over the world. And then every single human being on Earth would be given some amount of money, and the world would be bettered for it.
这是一件大家都会在网上参与的极其有趣的事情。筹集的资金将捐给世界各地的慈善机构。然后地球上的每一个人都会得到一定数量的钱，世界也会因此变得更美好。
One of the things that he included in his delusion, you write in your book, is that he has the thought that he actually was the mastermind who created this game show that he was on, and that he controlled it and he knew the rules when he had originally created the show. But somehow he had forgotten that and all the rules-- which is so interesting, because of course it's true. Like, he did invent the game show, and the only fact that he's missing is that it's not real. It's all in his own head.
你在书中写道，他妄想的内容之一是，他认为自己实际上是这个游戏节目的幕后策划者，他控制着节目，并且在最初创作节目时就了解规则。但不知何故，他忘记了这一点和所有的规则——这太有趣了，因为这当然是真的。就像他确实发明了这个游戏节目一样，他唯一忽略的事实是它不是真的。这一切都在他自己的脑海里。
That's an interesting way of putting it. It is kind of fantastical.
这是一种有趣的说法。这确实有点离奇。
And heartbreaking.
而且令人心碎。
It is.
确实如此。
Like, part of him knows he made it up.
比如，他内心深处知道是他编出来的。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
But he can't grasp the whole reality--
但他无法完全把握现实——
He does not remember-- like, at one point he suggests that he told his best friends, this is what I'm going to do. You're going to run the show, but you will now hypnotize me, and I will forget what we're talking about now so we can do this really good deed for humanity.
他不记得了——比如在某个时刻，他建议说他告诉了他最好的朋友，这就是我要做的。你们要经营这个节目，但你们现在要催眠我，我会忘记我们现在谈论的内容，这样我们就能为人类做这件善事了。
Some of these patients respond to treatment, some don't-- same as with other delusions and psychoses. But Dr. Gold says that if they do come back to reality--
这些病人中有些人对治疗有反应，有些人则没有——和其他妄想和精神疾病的情况一样。但戈德医生说，如果他们回到了现实——
Some feel great relief if they've been persecuted. It's quite embarrassing if you think about it. Every moment of your life-- I mean, when you're in the shower, literally everything is filmed. So they feel quite good about it. At the same time, there's a certain sadness that they're not particularly important.
有些人如果一直感到被迫害，会感到巨大的解脱。如果仔细想想，这相当尴尬。你生活的每一刻——我是说，当你在洗澡时，字面上的一切都被拍摄下来了。所以他们对（回到现实）感觉相当不错。与此同时，当他们意识到自己并不是特别重要时，会有一种悲伤感。
Do they miss being the most famous person in the world?
他们会怀念成为世界上最著名的人的感觉吗？
No question, there are some who feel that that's a huge loss. At the same time, I think they return to the notion that they're mentally ill, which in and of itself is an unfortunate and sad thing.
毫无疑问，有些人确实觉得那是一个巨大的损失。与此同时，我认为他们会回到自己患有精神疾病的认知中，这本身就是一件不幸且悲伤的事情。
Psychosis aside, I think this illustrates so clearly, there's a downside and an upside to being onstage for the whole world to see, a human spectacle against your will. And today on our program, we have people who became just that. They have an experience so few of us have that we all get to see from afar.
抛开精神病不谈，我认为这非常清楚地说明了在全世界面前登台表演的利弊，这是一场违背你意愿的人类奇观。今天在我们的节目中，有几位成为了那样的受访者。他们经历了一种极少数人拥有的体验，而我们所有人都从远处见证了这一切。
They are on display for everybody, and not because they chose it. What that feels like, the positive parts and the negative side, and the real life reality of the whole thing-- from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
他们被展示给所有人看，而不是因为他们自己的选择。那是一种什么样的感觉，积极的方面和负面的影响，以及整件事情在现实生活中的样子——这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "I Am the Eggplant, Goo Goo Goo Joob ." In the TV genre that's devoted to pure human spectacle, reality TV, you know, people fight drunkenly in hot tubs, they eat live spiders for money. But none of that can hold a candle to this show-- a show that aired in Japan all the way back in 1998. It was called Susunu! Denpa Shonen. And one of its segments in particular got the attention of one of our producers, Stephanie Foo.
第一幕，“我是茄子，咕咕咕”。在致力于展现纯粹人类奇观的电视类型——真人秀中，你知道，人们在热水浴缸里喝醉了打架，为了钱吃活蜘蛛。但这些都无法与这个节目相比——一个早在1998年就在日本播出的节目。它的名字叫《前进吧！电波少年》。其中的一个片段引起了我们制作人之一斯蒂芬妮·傅的注意。
The segment is called "Sweepstakes Life." It starts the way a lot of these shows do-- with a bunch of people at an audition. One guy beats out everyone else. He's 22 years old, a comedian just starting out in his career. His name is Nasubi.
该片段名为“中奖生活”。它像许多同类节目一样开始——一群人在试镜。一个人击败了所有人。他22岁，是一名刚开始职业生涯的喜剧演员。他的名字叫茄子（Nasubi）。
Nasubi!
茄子！
Nasubi means eggplant in Japanese-- a nickname he got because he has a long face. The producers tell him they have a unique idea for a show, something they've never tried before. It may or may not air, but if it does, he'll be the star. He'll be famous.
茄子在日语里就是茄子的意思——这个绰号是因为他有一张长脸。制作人告诉他，他们有一个独特的节目创意，以前从未尝试过。它可能会播出，也可能不会，但如果播出了，他就会成为明星。他会出名。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
The producers blindfold him, put him in a car, and take him to a small apartment. Then they tell him to take his clothes off.
制作人蒙住他的眼睛，把他放进车里，带到一个小公寓。然后他们告诉他把衣服脱了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
That wipes the grin off his face.
这抹去了他脸上的笑容。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
It wasn't just my personal sort of shame or sort of issues about nudity, per se. My dad is a cop. And when I first announced that for my career choice, it was going to be comedy, he was not thrilled. And we had to go through some things to get him around to the idea. And he said, the one thing that I must never do in public is strip.
这不仅仅是我个人关于裸体的羞耻感或问题本身。我爸爸是警察。当我第一次宣布我的职业选择是喜剧时，他并不激动。我们不得不经历一些事情才让他接受这个想法。他说，有一件事是我在公共场合绝对不能做的，那就是脱光衣服。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
So there I was. And then this guilt towards-- I was breaking the promise to my father as publicly as possible.
所以我就在那里。而且，我这种对父亲的愧疚——我在尽可能公开地违背对父亲的承诺。
But he strips. He grabs a pillow, holds it over his groin, and looks around the room. There's no chair in the room, no bed-- just a coffee table and magazines, tons of magazines. The producers tell him that from now on, if he wants food, clothes, he will have to win them by entering sweepstakes in those magazines. They give him postcards to send in for prize drawings.
但他还是脱了。他抓起一个枕头，盖住腹股沟，环顾房间。房间里没有椅子，没有床——只有一张咖啡桌和杂志，成堆的杂志。制作人告诉他，从现在开始，如果他想要食物、衣服，他就必须通过填写那些杂志里的抽奖券来赢取它们。他们给他明信片，让他寄出参加奖品抽奖。
He'll be freed from the apartment after he wins 1 million yen, or $10,000 worth of prizes. Until then, he isn't allowed any outside contact with the world. He can't call his family. He can't talk to friends. And oh, they tell him, don't forget to put tapes in this little camera here every two hours and record yourself. We'll come pick up the tapes once a day. Then they say, all right, later. Nasubi screams, are you for real?
在他赢到100万日元或价值1万美元的奖品后，他才能从公寓里被释放。在那之前，他不允许与外界有任何联系。他不能给家人打电话。他不能和朋友交谈。哦，他们还告诉他，别忘了每两小时往这台小摄像机里放一盘磁带并记录下自己。我们会每天来取一次磁带。然后他们说，好了，回头见。茄子尖叫道，你是认真的吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Nasubi says he'd signed no contract. But he didn't have anything better to do, so he sat down and wrote and soon was entering 200 to 300 contests a day. And while he waited for prizes to arrive, he had no food. Nasubi got frighteningly thin very quickly. You could see the sharp angles of his collarbones.
茄子说他没有签署任何合同。但他也没别的事可做，所以他坐下来开始写，很快每天要参加200到300场比赛。在他等待奖品送达时，他没有食物。茄子很快就瘦得可怕。你可以看到他锁骨的锐利棱角。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Well, starvation is a good word for it. The staff got together and would give me basically a very simple little bread each day, so I had bread and water essentially for the first two weeks. But then as soon as the results started to come in, then that stopped and everything shifted over entirely to things that I could win through sweepstakes.
嗯，饥饿是形容它的好词。工作人员聚在一起，基本上每天只给我一点非常简单的面包，所以前两周我基本上只吃面包和水。但一旦结果开始出来，这种情况就停止了，一切完全转移到了我可以通过抽奖赢取的东西上。
After two weeks, he finally won some sugary drinks. A few days after that, he won a bag of rice. When the postman dropped it off, it was like Christmas. Nasubi danced like a madman.
两周后，他终于赢得了一些含糖饮料。几天后，他赢得了一袋米。当邮递员把它放下时，就像圣诞节一样。茄子像个疯子一样跳舞。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Were you trying to be a good performer and be funny when you were doing that? Or was it just really genuine joy?
当你在做那些动作时，你是想做一个好演员并表现得滑稽吗？还是那真的是发自内心的喜悦？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Well, initially, of course, I was there as a performer, and I wanted to be a comedian. But somewhere in the middle, the whole business of staying alive became my full-time occupation. So I think what you saw if you saw me dancing, it was really just a human being expressing great joy.
嗯，最初，我当然是以表演者的身份在那里，我想成为一名喜剧演员。但在中间某个时候，维持生命这件事成了我的全职工作。所以我认为如果你看到我跳舞，那真的只是一个人在表达巨大的喜悦。
So he danced for this package of rice. But then he stopped short. He realized he didn't own a pot to cook the rice in. But after a couple days of failed attempts, he figured out that if he put some race in an empty drink container and left it near his single gas burner, it eventually turned into a kind of porridge.
所以他为了这包米而跳舞。但随后他停了下来。他意识到他没有煮饭的锅。但在经历了几天失败的尝试后，他发现如果把米放进一个空饮料容器里，放在单头煤气灶旁边，它最终会变成一种粥。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
And I could eat delicious rice every day. I remember how good that felt. And then there was this slow trepidation as it started to vanish. And then it ran out. And the only food substitute that I had been able to win in a sweepstakes was dog food. After, let's say, six weeks of eating dog food, when I was able to get more rice and it arrived, I really felt a special kind of joy at being able to sort of return to humanity in a sense and taste delicious rice again every day.
我可以每天吃上美味的米饭。我记得那感觉有多好。然后，当它开始消失时，有一种缓慢的恐惧感。最后它吃完了。我在抽奖中能赢到的唯一代餐是狗粮。在吃了一个月左右的狗粮后，当我能得到更多的米并且它送到时，我确实感受到了一种特殊的喜悦，因为我又回到了人性，每天又能吃到美味的米饭了。
Back then, there was a kind of sweepstakes mania in Japan. The country was in the middle of a terrible recession, and some wondered whether one could subsist entirely on their winnings. And so when "Sweepstakes Life" debuted, almost immediately after Nasubi was first shut in the room, it was an instant hit. Nasubi had no idea. He didn't even know he was on TV. He believed what the producers had told them, that he'd record some videotapes and maybe someday it would end up on the air.
那时，日本有一种抽奖热潮。国家正处于严重的经济衰退中，有些人想知道一个人是否能完全靠赢取的奖品生活。所以当“中奖生活”播出时，在茄子第一次被关进房间后几乎立刻就成了热门节目。茄子对此一无所知。他甚至不知道自己正在电视上。他相信制作人告诉他的话，说他只是录制一些录像带，也许有一天它会播出。
On television, Nasubi's groin was hidden by a purple cartoon eggplant that floated around as he moved. Everything he did was accentuated with ridiculous boing-boing sound effects and puffy rainbow letters floated above his head.
在电视上，茄子的腹股沟被一个随着他移动而漂浮的紫色卡通茄子遮住了。他所做的一切都伴随着荒谬的“砰砰”音效，他头顶上方飘浮着蓬松的彩虹字母。
[SOUND EFFECTS AND RANDOM JAPANESE SPEECH]
（音效和随机日语演讲）
But these effects popped up just as often when Nasubi was despondent. The show took every chance to poke fun at him, whether he was muttering to himself, dancing around, or doing terrible headstands-- you know, the dumb stuff you do when you think no one's watching.
但当茄子沮丧时，这些特效也会频繁出现。节目抓住每一个机会取笑他，无论他是在自言自语、跳舞，还是做着糟糕的倒立——你知道，当你认为没人看时做的那些蠢事。
Except, people were. For context, in the US, Game of Thrones usually has around 9 million viewers. Nasubi had 16 million in a country less than half the size of ours. People thought Nasubi was the funniest comedy act they'd ever seen. And I have to admit, as a viewer, once in a while when Nasubi got something really awesome in the mail, I couldn't help it, I laughed too. Even though I knew how much he was suffering, I couldn't help it. His unfiltered joy is contagious.
除了一点，确实有人在看。作为背景，在美国，《权力的游戏》通常有大约900万观众。茄子在一个面积不到我们一半的国家里拥有1600万观众。人们认为茄子是他们见过最有趣的喜剧表演。我不得不承认，作为观众，偶尔当茄子真的收到什么超级棒的东西时，我忍不住也会笑。即使我知道他受了多少苦，我也控制不住。他那未经修饰的喜悦具有感染力。
Though, as a foreigner watching "Sweepstakes Life," most of the time when the studio audience cracked up, I felt sick. I thought, what could possibly be funny about this?
尽管，作为一个观看“中奖生活”的外国人，大多数时候当演播室观众大笑时，我感到恶心。我想，这有什么好笑的？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
I mean, that was maybe a time when Japan was going through some things, and they need to sort of do that. Roughly 50 years of prosperity has finally come to a close, and people were really uncertain about their futures. I think people just tended to watch the show and say, I got it bad, but look at poor Nasubi. He's got it worse.
我的意思是，那可能是一个日本经历了一些事情的时期，他们需要那样做。大约50年的繁荣终于画上了句号，人们对未来感到非常不确定。我认为人们倾向于看这个节目并说，我的处境很糟糕，但看看可怜的茄子。他更惨。
Now there's a lot more awareness of the weak and of people who need extra support. And I don't think the average Japanese, they would think it was funny that there was a guy naked in a room somewhere.
现在人们对弱势群体和需要额外支持的人有了更多的认识。我不认为一般的日本人会觉得房间里有个裸体男人很滑稽。
Nasubi won hundreds of prizes, but many of them were useless to him-- Spice Girls tickets, for example, or a TV with no cable, or a bicycle. He sent away for clothes but never won anything he could wear. He was naked the entire time he was in that room, for the entire show. And as the weeks went by, then months, Nasubi started to look less and less sane. He grew a beard. His hair was wild. And he started talking differently, slower.
茄子赢得了数百个奖品，但其中许多对他来说毫无用处——比如辣妹组合的门票，或者没有电缆的电视机，或者自行车。他寄信索要衣服，但从没赢到过他能穿的东西。他在房间里的整个时间，整个节目期间，都是裸体的。随着几周过去，然后是几个月，茄子看起来越来越不像个正常人。他留起了胡子。他的头发很凌乱。他开始以不同的方式说话，更慢。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
He'd make really creepy faces into the camera. At one point, he won some toys, and he started talking to them. He took a stuffed seal for a walk around the apartment. An action figure became his sensei, and he got life advice from it.
他会对着镜头做非常令人毛骨悚然的表情。有一次，他赢了一些玩具，并开始和它们说话。他带着一个毛绒海豹在公寓里走来走去。一个动作玩偶成了他的老师，他从中得到了生活建议。
And if right now you are sitting there thinking, how in God's good name is this possible? Why was this allowed-- imprisonment, solitary confinement, starvation. Watching I thought, this isn't a reality TV show. It's a psychological experiment made public. Plus, boing-boings, of course.
如果此时你正坐在那里想，天哪，这怎么可能？为什么允许这样做——监禁、单独监禁、饥饿。看着节目，我想，这不是真人秀。这是一个被公开的心理实验。再加上“砰砰”的音效，当然。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Was there anything preventing you from backing out at that point? Like, was the door locked?
那时有什么阻止你退出的吗？门锁了吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
No, there was no lock on the door. And producers later asked me, so why didn't you escape? And I was naked, so I would have had to go outside naked and seek help. But I don't think that that's what kept me in there. The only thing I really have to say is that I said I'd do it, and I do what I say.
不，门上没有锁。制作人后来问我，那你为什么不逃跑呢？我当时是裸体的，所以我不得不裸体跑出去寻求帮助。但我认为那并不是留住我的原因。我唯一要说的是，我说过我会做到，而且我说到做到。
That was it? The only reason? I kept asking him, but wait, really, why?
就是这样？唯一的理由？我一直在问他，等等，真的，为什么？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
There's a phrase, [SPEAKING JAPANESE], the Japanese spirit, which is just that you sort of stick through. You endure things. When you're given something, whether it's easier or whether it's hard, you just really do-- you're obliged to follow it through.
有一个短语，“大和魂”，日本精神，意思就是你坚持到底。你忍受事情。当你被赋予某件事时，无论是容易还是困难，你都不得不坚持到底。
Nasubi did finally win $10,000 worth of prizes. It took him almost an entire year, but at last, he completed the challenge. When he reached his goal, producers didn't tell him anything about it. Instead, they snuck into his apartment in the middle of the night, put a blindfold on him, took him out to a car, gave him clothes. Nasubi seemed to think this was a good thing. He was laughing, giggling.
茄子最终确实赢得了价值1万美元的奖品。他花了几乎整整一年，但最终他完成了挑战。当他达到目标时，制作人什么也没告诉他。相反，他们半夜溜进他的公寓，蒙上他的眼睛，把他带到车上，给了他衣服。茄子似乎认为这是一件好事。他在笑，在咯咯笑。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
But when he took the blindfold off, he found out, he'd been taken to Korea.
但当他摘下眼罩时，他发现自己被带到了韩国。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
When I got off on the other side in Korea, I took off the mask. And they said, congratulations. You've achieved your $10,000. This is your reward. You get to have a trip in Korea. So I got to do a little sightseeing that day. And I thought, wow, that was a long thing, boy, what I've been through. But then at the end of the day, they took me back to my room, and there was the exact same room set up in the exact same way.
当我在韩国那边下车时，我摘下了面具。他们说，恭喜。你已经赢得了1万美元。这是你的奖励。你可以去韩国旅游。所以我那天参观了一些地方。我想，哇，这真是个漫长的过程，天哪，我经历了什么。但到了一天结束时，他们把我带回了我的房间，一模一样的房间，以完全相同的方式布置。
They had recreated his little apartment, complete with the magazines, the stuffed seal, the postcards, exactly how he'd left it, except in Korea. And they told him, great, now all you have to do is start over and win your airfare back home.
他们重建了他的小公寓，连同杂志、毛绒海豹、明信片，和他离开时一模一样，只不过是在韩国。他们告诉他，太好了，现在你所要做的就是从头开始，赢取回家的机票。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
This was just like somebody just had pulled the floor out from under me, and I just fell. I didn't know that humans could be that cruel.
就像有人抽走了我脚下的地板，我掉下去了。我没想到人类竟然可以如此残忍。
Did you feel like you were going insane?
你觉得你快疯了吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
If anything, the opposite of insane. I lost all energy. It's like somebody had just sucked the life out of me. I didn't want to talk. I didn't want to breathe. I didn't want to move a muscle. I had reached the end. I was just-- I was finished.
如果有的话，恰恰相反。我失去了所有能量。就像有人刚刚吸走了我的生命。我不想说话。我不想呼吸。我不想动一下肌肉。我走到了尽头。我只是——我完了。
I told the producer that I wouldn't do it. I refused. And we went back and forth for quite a while, actually. But in the end-- kudos to his skill as a negotiator-- I did give in and do the last section of it.
我告诉制作人我不会做。我拒绝了。实际上，我们僵持了很久。但最后——不得不夸奖他的谈判技巧——我屈服并完成了最后一部分。
Why did you do it? What did he say that actually convinced you to do it?
你为什么这么做？他说了什么才真正说服了你去做？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Well, it was just I got exhausted, if anything. I mean, he wasn't leaving. I couldn't just sort of get up and storm out. I had made no preparations for being in Korea. And so at the end, I just said, yeah, whatever. And so I continued.
好吧，我只是筋疲力尽了。我的意思是，他并没有离开。我不能就这样起身冲出去。我没准备好在韩国生活。所以最后，我就说，好吧，随便吧。所以我继续了。
After all, he was naked with no money in another country. If you watch the clip, the producers just tell him he's trapped, show him looking shocked, and cut away. The studio audience laughs.
毕竟，他在另一个国家，身无分文，赤身裸体。如果你看那个片段，制作人只是告诉他他被困住了，显示他震惊的样子，然后切掉。演播室的观众大笑。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER AND JAPANESE SPEECH]
（观众笑声和日语演讲）
Nasubi continued his writing routine for four more months. And then the final episode aired. Picture it-- the producers sneak into Nasubi's room and blindfold him again, dress him, drive him to another location. They release him in yet another bare room. And he sighs and instinctively takes off all his clothes. Then suddenly, all four of the walls around him fall down.
茄子又坚持写了四个月。然后最后一集播出了。想象一下——制作人溜进茄子的房间，再次蒙住他的眼睛，给他穿上衣服，带到另一个地方。他们把他释放到另一个空荡荡的房间里。他叹了口气，本能地脱掉了所有的衣服。然后突然，他周围所有的四面墙都倒塌了。
[WALLS CRASHING]
（墙壁倒塌的声音）
[SCREAMING]
（尖叫声）
That's him screaming. Turns out, he's onstage in a huge studio in Japan in front of an enormous audience.
那是他的尖叫声。事实证明，他正站在日本一个巨大的演播室里，面前是成千上万的观众。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Nasubi, congratulations on your goal.
茄子，恭喜你完成目标。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Nasubi looks horrified. Two television hosts cautiously approach him and talk to him like a baby, telling him, congratulations.
茄子看起来很惊恐。两个电视主持人谨慎地走近他，像对他说话一样对他说话，告诉他，恭喜。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Nasubi says, frightened, my house fell down, and there's all these people here.
茄子害怕地说，我的房子倒塌了，这里怎么有这么多人。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
It's finally over, presses the host. You're finished. Nasubi should be happy, but he looks thoroughly weirded out. Remember, Nasubi didn't even know he was being broadcast. The producers told him that it was an experiment, that they didn't know if he'd ever make it on air. So he's blown away when they tell him about the TV show, that a secret camera in his apartment once even broadcast at 24-hour live stream of his actions. They tell him his diaries were published and are best sellers. Clips from him enjoying a specific brand of ramen turned into commercial and endorsement deals. He was on the cover of magazines.
“终于结束了，”主持人按捺不住地说，“你完成了。”茄子应该很高兴，但他看起来彻底被弄糊涂了。记住，茄子甚至不知道自己正在被广播。制作人告诉他这是一个实验，他们不知道他是否会播出。所以当他们告诉他关于电视节目的事，告诉他公寓里的秘密摄像头甚至曾经24小时直播他的行为时，他惊呆了。他们告诉他他的日记已经出版并成为畅销书。他享受特定品牌拉面的视频变成了商业广告和代言协议。他登上了杂志封面。
Then they play a bunch of clips from the show. Nasubi blinks. He says, did I do that? That was me?
然后他们播放了一堆节目片段。茄子眨了眨眼睛。他说，那是我做的吗？那是当时的我？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
And so I sat there realizing that this new sort of life was-- you know, I was no longer just a nobody. The entire nation had been watching me for 15 months. And you know, to be honest, I thought, well, what the hell's-- what is my country coming to? And I was, you know, very happy that my journey was not for nothing. But it's still weird.
所以我坐在那里意识到，这种新生活——你知道，我不再只是个无名小卒了。整个国家已经看了我15个月。老实说，我想，到底怎么了？我的国家怎么了？我很高兴我的旅程没有白费。但那依然很奇怪。
Unsurprisingly, Nasubi left the show with some scars. He had a lot of trouble holding a conversation for six months. And he felt sweaty and uncomfortable in clothes for a year. And his role didn't help his comedy career like he'd hoped. He was mostly offered roles that required him to be goofy and naked. He's a D-list celebrity now and has the dwindling bank account to match.
不出所料，茄子离开节目后留下了一些伤疤。他有六个月的时间很难进行对话。他穿衣服感到出汗和不舒服持续了一年。他的角色并没有像他希望的那样帮助他的喜剧事业。他得到的角色大多需要他表现得愚蠢和赤身裸体。他现在是三线明星，银行账户也在缩水。
In talking to him, it felt like he's really worked hard to turn that traumatic experience into a positive story he tells himself. He even says he's thankful for the experience.
在与他交谈时，感觉他确实付出了很大努力，试图将那段痛苦的经历转化为他告诉自己的一个积极故事。他甚至说他很感激那段经历。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
It was-- I don't want to overstate it, but it was kind of meditative in a way. I had a lot of time to think about my life and a lot of time to think about a lot of stuff.
那段经历——我不想夸大其词，但它在某种程度上是一种冥想。我有很多时间思考我的人生，有很多时间思考很多事情。
That certainly is a very zen way to look at it.
那确实是一种非常禅宗的看待方式。
Well, I mean, it's 10-some years since I finished, since I did that project. And after that, everything has been much easier and much better. I mean, obviously I'm able to deal with things. I see things happening, or I see situations around myself. And I think, that's nothing like what I went through in that room.
好吧，我的意思是，距离我完成那个项目已经过去10多年了。从那以后，一切都变得容易多了，也好了很多。我的意思是，显然我有能力处理事情。我看到事情发生，或者看到周围的情况。然后我想，那和我在那个房间里经历的根本算不了什么。
And people still remember him. That's more than one could say for most of the other Denpa Shonen characters. None of them lasted as long as Nasubi or became as famous. The show ended in 2002, after its ratings began to drop.
人们仍然记得他。对于大多数其他的电波少年角色来说，这算是不错的了。他们中没有一个人能像茄子那样坚持那么久，也没有变得那么出名。该节目于2002年停播，因为收视率开始下降。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
I came out of the whole thing, in a sense, with the very best of possible results. A lot of people were not so fortunate. There were terrible things that happened related to the show.
某种意义上，我从整个事情中获得了尽可能好的结果。很多人没那么幸运。节目相关发生了一些可怕的事情。
One contestant on Denpa Shonen almost died of dehydration while trying to hitchhike across Africa. Some people were starved until they completed various challenges. Another man was forced to go into a gay club in Australia and offer condoms to men until he was assaulted. The video cuts out, but you can hear him scream.
电波少年的一名参赛者在试图搭车横穿非洲时差点死于脱水。一些人被饿到完成各种挑战。另一个人被迫走进澳大利亚的一家同性恋俱乐部，并向男人们提供避孕套，直到他遭到袭击。视频切断了，但你可以听到他的尖叫声。
And the mastermind behind all this, the producer of the show, the guy who convinced Nasubi to keep going in Korea-- his name was Toshio Tsuchiya. Back in the '90s, he was considered the king of Japanese reality TV. Last year, 14 years after "Sweepstakes Life" ended, Tsuchiya called Nasubi, who wasn't thrilled to hear from him at first.
而这一切的幕后黑手，节目的制作人，那个在韩国说服茄子继续坚持下去的家伙——他的名字叫土屋敏男。在90年代，他被认为是日本真人秀之王。去年，也就是“中奖生活”结束14年后，土屋给茄子打了电话，茄子起初并不乐意接到他的电话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
I had some, let's say, mixed feelings about him, a little resentment maybe. Yeah. I kept my distance for a very long time. And then actually just last year, he got in touch with me. And apparently it sort of came to his attention that maybe he had put people through maybe more than they deserved. And so he invited me to dinner. And he spent the evening sort of explaining why he did what he did and apologizing. I think we-- yeah, I think we pretty much came to terms, and I welcome the opportunity to work with him again, certainly.
我对他的感觉很复杂，也许还有一点怨恨。是的。我保持了很长一段时间的距离。事实上就在去年，他联系了我。显然他注意到他可能让人们经历了超出他们应得的苦难。所以他请我吃饭。他花了一个晚上解释他为什么那么做并道歉。我想我们——是的，我想我们基本达成和解了，我当然欢迎有机会再次与他合作。
Wow. You would work with him again? That's really-- that's shocking. And what was his reason for putting you through what  he did?
哇。你还会再和他合作？那真的很——令人震惊。他让你经历那些事情的原因是什么？
He wanted something that would move people, and you don't get that out of just sort of somebody playing around. He wanted to see something real. He wanted to pull miracles out of people. And he wanted to-- it was done for the purpose of getting a miracle on film.
他想要一些能打动人的东西，你不可能只从一个玩闹的人身上得到这些。他想看到真实的东西。他想从人们身上挖掘奇迹。他想要——这样做是为了在电影中获得一个奇迹。
And that seemed to me like-- well, I'll be honest, it sounds like something an evil puppet master would say. So I had to. I talked to Toshio Tsuchiya on the phone. He's a round, middle-aged guy, bleached platinum blond hair. He confirmed that he reached out to Nasubi and that when they met, Nasubi told him very honestly how painful his experience on the show was.
这对我来说听起来像——老实说，这听起来像邪恶的傀儡师会说的话。所以我必须这样做。我通过电话和土屋敏男谈过。他是一个圆润的中年男人，留着漂白的白金金色头发。他证实他联系了茄子，当他们见面时，茄子非常诚实地告诉他他在节目中的经历是多么痛苦。
Tsuchiya says he listened and was moved. But, he says, he wasn't sorry-- about Nasubi, about any of the segments he produced for Denpa Shonen , about any of the contestants. Not in the slightest. I use the same interpreter for our interview that I use for Nasubi's. Here's Tsuchiya.
土屋说他听了并很感动。但是，他说，他不后悔——关于茄子，关于他为《电波少年》制作的任何片段，关于任何参赛者。一点也不。我在采访中使用的是和茄子采访中使用的同一位口译员。这是土屋。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
I was enthralled by their struggle. I was thrilled by their personal struggle. So I was watching them succeed. I have no regrets about anything I did on that show.
我被他们的挣扎所吸引。我被他们个人的奋斗所感动。所以我看着他们成功。我不后悔在那个节目中做的任何事情。
Nasubi said that you apologized to him when you guys talked. Is that correct, or no?
茄子说你们交谈时你向他道歉了。这是真的吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
Well, I put him through a lot. I'm not-- if you say that you have a sports team and you have a coach who runs his players through very difficult maneuvers, at the end of the day, he may pat him on the back and say, sorry for putting you through such a rough struggle. It wasn't me expressing that I shouldn't have done the project.
好吧，我让他经历了很多。我不是——如果你说你有一支运动队，有一个教练带他的队员进行非常困难的操练，在一天结束时，他可能会拍拍他的背说，抱歉让你经历了这么艰难的挣扎。那并不是我表达我不应该做这个项目。
Tsuchiya has a lot of lofty ideas of what the show was trying to accomplish. And when he talks about them, you do get the sense that it was in fact intended to be a sort of psychological experiment.
土屋对节目试图完成的事情有很多高谈阔论。当他谈论这些时，你会感觉到它实际上确实意图成为一种心理实验。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
（日语对话）
The whole project was trying to reach at some very elemental simple humanity. You see, Nasubi had been sort of brought to a state where he was in such an elemental part of his existence that he danced without realizing he had ever danced. And he danced on a regular basis. The modern individual is sort of shackled by convention and expectation and all these other things that we wear from day to day. And I wanted to see them drop some of that to see this simple humanity and then to see actual gratefulness.
整个项目试图触及一些非常基础、简单的人性。你看，茄子被带入了一种状态，他的存在处于如此基础的部分，以至于他跳舞时都没意识到自己跳过舞。而且他定期跳舞。现代个体被传统、期望以及我们每天所承受的所有其他东西所束缚。我想要看到他们放下其中的一些，去见证这种简单的人性，然后见证真正的感激之情。
It's weird to think about. But the fact that the matter is what Tsuchiya's saying is true. Denpa Shonen did really capture humanity in a rare way, a way you don't ever really see, even on the craziest of American reality TV shows. Hungry, starving, alone, unaware that he was being watched, Nasubi was totally innocent and totally animal. Of course, it's cruel to bring a human being to that point, and it takes a special kind of cruelty to take someone at their most vulnerable and add wacky sound effects to their suffering.
这想起来很奇怪。但事实是土屋所说的是真的。电波少年确实以一种罕见的方式捕捉到了人性，这种方式你真的看不到，即使是在最疯狂的美国真人秀节目中。饥饿、瘦弱、孤独、不知道自己正在被监视，茄子完全无辜，也完全像动物。当然，把一个人逼到那种程度是残忍的，把某人最脆弱的一面拿出来并为他们的痛苦加上古怪的音效，这需要一种特殊的残忍。
A couple weeks into Nasubi's challenge, before he won any solid food, when he was hungriest, a delivery men came to the door bearing ramen and stir fry vegetables. It's 1700 yen altogether, the man said. I don't have any money, Nasubi replied. Sorry, my mistake, the delivery man said, and left.
茄子的挑战进行了几周后，在他赢得任何固体食物之前，在他最饥饿的时候，一名送货员来到门口，带着拉面和炒蔬菜。总共1700日元，那人说。我没钱，茄子回答。抱歉，我弄错了，送货员说，然后走了。
Nasubi sat there, his head hung, a contestant in a real-life hunger game, the smell of ramen lingering in the air.
茄子坐在那里，低着头，这是一个现实生活中饥饿游戏的参赛者，拉面的香味在空气中飘荡。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, we go to a land where highway [INAUDIBLE] are sunk in a vast meadow, where one man tries to document how things really are. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，我们将去往一个高速公路[音频模糊]沉入广阔草地的地方，那里有一个人试图记录事情的真相。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, human spectacle. We have stories of people who go on display in front of others-- lots and lots of others-- even though they are not so crazy about doing that.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，人类奇观。我们有一些关于那些被展示在他人面前的人的故事——很多很多他人——即使他们并不热衷于那样做。
We have arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, "I Always Feel Like Somebody's Watching Me." We've talked a lot in today's program so far about reality TV. And of course, what makes reality TV entertaining is very, very simple. And that is editing.
我们已经进入了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，“我总觉得有人在注视着我。”到目前为止，我们在今天的节目中谈了很多关于真人秀的事情。当然，让真人秀具有娱乐性的是非常非常简单的东西。那就是编辑。
Editing-- if they just set up cameras and showed you all 24 hours in anybody's day, how interesting could that possibly be? Well, here is a story of somebody trying just that, a story of everyday people being treated as human spectacle and being treated that way precisely because of their everyday-ness. Ariel Sabar explains.
编辑——如果他们只是架设摄像头，向你展示任何人的24小时生活，那能有多有趣？好吧，这里是一个人尝试这样做的故事，一个普通人被当作人类奇观对待，并且正是因为他们的普通性而被那样对待的故事。阿里尔·萨巴对此进行了解释。
Here's how it worked. On a Tuesday morning in the spring of 1949, a seven-year-old boy named Raymond Birch was fast asleep in his bed. His mother walked into his bedroom and said, Raymond, time to get up for school. When the boy opened his eyes, he saw a scientist with a clipboard and timer standing in the corner of his room. The scientist, a stranger to the boy, just stared-- didn't say a word. The boy squirmed out of bed and reached for his clothes. The scientist wrote, 7:01 AM, Raymond picked up a sock.
它是这样工作的。1949年春天的某个周二早晨，一个叫雷蒙德·伯奇的七岁男孩正在床上熟睡。他妈妈走进卧室说，雷蒙德，起床上学的时间到了。当男孩睁开眼睛时，他看到一个拿着写字板和计时器的科学家站在房间角落。那个科学家，对男孩来说是个陌生人，只是盯着看——一言不发。男孩从床上爬起来，伸手去拿衣服。科学家写道，早上7:01，雷蒙德拿了一只袜子。
In the late 1940s and early '50s, scientists followed kids in houses, schoolyards, and streets across the town of Oskaloosa, Kansas, taking pages of notes on the littlest things they did or said. 6:33 PM, Bradley walked deliberately to where his sister sat playing with a puppy and hit her on the head twice, just as hard as he could hit. The sister looked very surprised and annoyed. 11:06 AM, Fred skidded on the floor so that he fell with his body partially under the swing. He yelled whoops, and then lay still since he saw the swing coming back over him. 11:37 AM, Margaret's mother asked, why can't you play with your dolls and let that go? Margaret kept on painting the pillars before, neither looking at her mother nor answering her.
在20世纪40年代末和50年代初，科学家们跟随堪萨斯州奥斯卡卢萨镇各地的孩子们在家里、学校操场和街道上，对他们做出的或说的最小的事情做笔记。下午6:33，布拉德利特意走到他妹妹坐着玩小狗的地方，并重重地敲了她头两下，尽量用他能用的最大的力气。妹妹看起来非常惊讶和恼火。上午11:06，弗雷德在地板上滑倒，身体部分滑到了秋千下面。他大喊“哎呀”，然后静止不动，因为他看到秋千正朝他摆过来。上午11:37，玛格丽特的母亲问，你为什么不能玩你的娃娃而让那个过去呢？玛格丽特继续画着柱子，既没看她母亲也没回答她。
All of this was happening under the watch of a University of Kansas psychologist named Roger Barker, who was bent on taking his field in a radically new direction. Because psychology was still struggling in those days to be taken seriously as a science, most of Barker's colleagues imitated other kinds of scientists, doing lots of experiments in labs.
这一切都在堪萨斯大学心理学家罗杰·巴克的注视下进行，他决心将自己的领域引向一个激进的新方向。由于心理学在那个时代仍在努力被严肃地视为一门科学，巴克的许多同事都在模仿其他类型的科学家，在实验室里做大量的实验。
But none of this made sense to Barker. Humans didn't live in laboratories. They live in the real world. And that's where Barker wanted to study them-- in the wild, the way a botanist looked at flowers in the field or a primatologist tracked apes through a forest.
但这对巴克来说毫无意义。人类不生活在实验室里。他们生活在现实世界中。而那正是巴克想要研究他们的地方——在野外，就像植物学家观察田野里的花朵，或者灵长类动物学家在森林中追踪猿类一样。
So when the University of Kansas called in 1947 and asked Barker if he wanted to chair its psychology department, Barker said, I'll take the job, but on one condition. You find me a small town. A dean at the school said he knew just the place, Oskaloosa, population 725.
所以当堪萨斯大学在1947年打电话问巴克是否想担任其心理学系主任时，巴克说，我接这份工作，但有一个条件。你们得给我找个小镇。学校的一位院长说他知道有这么个地方，奥斯卡卢萨，人口725人。
When Roger Barker first drove up into the hills of Northeastern Kansas to see Oskaloosa, he must have been beside himself. The place was a Norman Rockwell painting-- not too rich, not too poor, sturdy families in modest houses. It was the picture of Middle America.
当罗杰·巴克第一次驱车进入堪萨斯州东北部的群山看到奥斯卡卢萨时，他一定欣喜若狂。那个地方简直就像诺曼·洛克威尔的画作——不富裕也不贫穷，坚实的家庭住在朴素的房子里。它是美国中部的写照。
Barker wanted to study what he called "the naturally occurring behavior of free-ranging persons." And to do that, he told his field workers to become part of the scenery-- visible and friendly but not obtrusive. The last thing we want to do, he said, is give people the Guinea pig feeling.
巴克想要研究他所谓的“自由人自然发生的行为”。为了做到这一点，他告诉他的实地工作者要成为风景的一部分——显眼而友好，但不要突兀。他说，我们要做的最后一件事，就是让人们产生实验室小白鼠的感觉。
Barker took his own advice and moved his entire family to Oskaloosa. They settled in a beat-up house near the town square, joined the Presbyterian church, and became active in the town's social and civic organizations. And that left Barker just as exposed as the Oskaloosans he planned to put under his microscope. You'll be watching us, a local mother told the researchers one day. But don't forget, we'll be watching you.
巴克采纳了自己的建议，把全家搬到了奥斯卡卢萨。他们定居在城镇广场附近一栋破旧的房子里，加入了长老会，并活跃在该镇的社会和公民组织中。这让巴克和打算放进显微镜下研究的奥斯卡卢萨人一样暴露无遗。“你们会监视我们，”一位当地母亲有一天对研究人员说。“但别忘了，我们也会监视你们。”
One of the first things Barker wanted to do in Oskaloosa was to document a day in the life of an ordinary boy. Barker didn't have a hypothesis about the boy or about seven-year-olds. He wasn't testing for anything in particular. He wanted only to show the world that following a kid for a day could produce a ton of interesting data. Scientists could later break down that data in an infinite number of ways, depending on their interests and the goals of their research, which was how little Raymond Birch work up that morning to find a scientist standing over him.
巴克在奥斯卡卢萨想做的第一件事就是记录一个普通男孩一天的生活。巴克对这个男孩或七岁孩子没有任何假设。他没有测试任何特定的东西。他只想向世界证明，跟随一个孩子一天可以产生大量有趣的数据。科学家们以后可以根据自己的兴趣和研究目标，以无数种方式分析这些数据，这就是小雷蒙德·伯奇那天早上醒来发现一个科学家站在他身旁的原因。
On that Tuesday, April 26, 1949, eight researchers taking turns, like runners in a relay race, followed Raymond for 13 hours straight. The book that came out of it, One Boy's Day was 435 pages long. It had an entry for nearly every minute of Raymond's day. The researchers tried to record not just Raymond's words and movements, but also his perceptions, motives, and feelings. They noted that Raymond mumbled with a mouthful of toast at breakfast. They followed him as he walked with his mom to her job at the county clerk's office and looked on as he drew a picture of a cowboy with a long beard. They watched Raymond find a baseball bat in the grass and pick it up. Oh, boy, he said, according to their notes.
在那天，1949年4月26日周二，八名研究人员轮流，就像接力赛中的跑步者一样，跟随雷蒙德整整13个小时。由此产生的书《一个男孩的一天》有435页长。它几乎涵盖了雷蒙德一天中每一分钟的记录。研究人员试图记录的不仅仅是雷蒙德的话语和动作，还有他的感知、动机和感受。他们注意到雷蒙德早餐时嘴里塞满了烤面包在嘀咕。他们跟着他和他妈妈步行到县书记官办公室上班，并看着他画了一张长胡子的牛仔图片。他们看着雷蒙德在草地上找到了一根棒球棒并捡了起来。根据笔记，他说，哦，伙计。
He tossed a stone in the air and swung but accidentally clipped a flagpole, 8:24 AM. This made a wonderful, hollow ringing noise. So he proceeded to hit the flagpole again. 8:25 AM, he went around and around and around the pole, hitting it with the bat as he did so, until he became so busy that he fell down, bat and all.
他把一块石头抛向空中挥棒，但意外地擦到了旗杆，早上8:24。这发出了一声美妙、空洞的回响声。所以他继续再次敲打旗杆。早上8:25，他绕着旗杆一圈又一圈地转，敲打着旗杆，直到他太忙而摔倒了，连球棒一起摔倒。
Even before the book about Raymond's day was published, Barker felt it was destined for greatness. It would find its way onto campuses as a staple of psychology courses, he thought, and into the hands of artists, novelists, and laymen interested in the cultural scene. "We believe it will become a sort of classic and be in demand for a long time," he wrote in a January, 1951, letter.
甚至在关于雷蒙德一天的书出版之前，巴克就觉得它注定会名垂青史。他认为，它会进入校园成为心理学课程的核心，并进入对文化场景感兴趣的艺术家、小说家和外行人的手中。“我们相信它会成为一种经典，并长期受到追捧，”他在1951年1月的一封信中写道。
But One Boy's Day never took off. And by April, 1959, Barker, crestfallen, asked Harper and Row to ship him the 70 remainders languishing in its warehouse. Part of the trouble was simply the book's premise. In its defiant first sentence, Barker calls the book "a scientific document."
但《一个男孩的一天》从未流行起来。到1959年4月，沮丧的巴克要求哈珀-柯林斯出版社将滞留在仓库里的70本剩余书籍运给他。部分问题仅仅在于这本书的前提。在挑衅性的第一句话中，巴克称这本书为“一份科学文件”。
But other scientists had a hard time seeing that. The book was just a tick-tock chronology of Raymond's day. There wasn't any theory or analysis. And this annoyed many of the reviewers in serious academic journals. One reviewer wrote, "The reader is struck by the fact that he is encountering only raw data. How can one evaluate such materials without a theoretical framework?" In other words, what does it mean?
但其他科学家很难那样看待它。这本书只是雷蒙德一天的滴答计时年代记录。没有任何理论或分析。这惹恼了许多严肃学术期刊的评论员。一位评论员写道，“读者惊讶地发现他遇到的只是原始数据。没有理论框架，怎么能评估这些材料？”换句话说，这意味着什么？
Barker lived in Oskaloosa the rest of his life, but he abandoned his day-in-the-life studies after just a few years. There were more revealing and less labor intensive ways, he discovered, to study human beings in their natural habitats. Today, field studies of naturally occurring behavior are no more common in psychology than they were in Barker's time. The cost and logistics are just too staggering. One rare but recent Barker-like effort was conducted by UCLA's Center on the Everyday Life of Families. Researchers there embedded in the homes of 32 middle-class families in Los Angeles for a week and videotaped nearly every waking minute.
巴克在奥斯卡卢萨度过了余生，但仅仅几年后就放弃了他的“一天生活”研究。他发现，在人类的自然栖息地研究他们，有比这更具揭示性且劳动强度更低的方法。今天，自然发生行为的实地研究在心理学中并不比巴克时代更常见。成本和后勤工作实在太惊人了。一个罕见但最近的类似巴克的尝试是由加州大学洛杉矶分校的家庭日常生活中心进行的。那里的研究人员在一周内嵌入了洛杉矶32个中产阶级家庭的家中，并将几乎每一分钟清醒时间都录了下来。
But the ratio of cost and effort to interesting results remains as lopsided today as it was in Barker's time. The New York Times reported that, quote, "After more than $9 million and untold thousands of hours of video watching, the researchers found that, well, life in these trenches is exactly what it looks like-- a fireshower of stress, multitasking, and mutual nitpicking."
但成本和努力与有趣结果的比例今天依然和巴克时代一样失衡。《纽约时报》报道称，引用，“在花费超过900万美元和无数数千小时的视频观看后，研究人员发现，好吧，在这些战壕里的生活和看起来的一样——一场压力、多任务处理和相互挑剔的火雨。”
One guy in particular who's not a big fan of these studies-- Raymond Birch, the boy. I tracked him down a few years ago. His real name is Gary Morgan, and he's now a retired utility worker in his early 70s living in Pennsylvania. Roger Barker autographed Gary's copy of One Boy's Day and personally inscribed, calling Gary its, quote, "real author."
特别是一个对这些研究不太感冒的人——雷蒙德·伯奇，那个男孩。几年前我找到了他。他的真名是加里·摩根，现在是一位70出头、住在宾夕法尼亚州的退休公用事业工人。罗杰·巴克在加里的《一个男孩的一天》副本上亲笔签名，并题词，称加里为该书的“真正作者”。
But Gary has yet to get past its first pages. I have to say, why is this interesting, he told me. There's nothing happening in this book as far as I can tell. What is it going to tell them that I was standing there, chewing on my fingernails?
但加里还没有读过前几页。他告诉我，我不得不说，为什么这很有趣？据我所知，这本书里什么都没发生。这能告诉他们什么？我站在那里，咬我的指甲吗？
Ariel Sabar is the author of The Outsider , a biography of Roger Barker. It's available as an Amazon Kindle single.
阿里尔·萨巴是《局外人》的作者，这是罗杰·巴克的传记。它作为亚马逊Kindle单行本提供。
[MUSIC - "CENTER OF ATTENTION", BY GUSTER]
（音乐 - Guster的“关注中心”）
Act Three, "I Am Iraq, I Am an Island." These last few awful weeks in Iraq-- as The New York Times put it, Jjihadists are entrenching positions in the north and west, the National Army seems incapable of challenging them. Lots of fighting, lots of death-- the website Iraq Body Count says that over 1,700 people have died this month, the highest number of deaths of any month since 2007.
第三幕，“我是伊拉克，我是一座孤岛。”伊拉克过去几周极其可怕——正如《纽约时报》所说，圣战分子正在北部和西部加固阵地，国民军似乎无力挑战他们。大量的战斗，大量的死亡——伊拉克死亡人数统计网站称，这个月有超过1700人死亡，是自2007年以来死亡人数最多的一个月。
With all that happening, the people of Iraq have become a reluctant spectacle for the rest of us around the world. There's been excellent coverage of the breaking news here on public radio and elsewhere too, but we wondered how it is looking to people inside the country. What are they saying? And what is it like to be living there right now? So between Thursday of last week-- that's June 19-- and Tuesday of this week-- that's June 24-- Nancy Updike called around Iraq to find out.
随着这一切的发生，伊拉克人民已成为我们世界各地其他人不情愿的奇观。这里的突发新闻有极好的报道，公共广播电台和其他媒体也有，但我们想知道这对国内的人来说是什么样子。他们在说什么？现在住在那里是什么感觉？所以，从上周四——也就是6月19日——到本周二——也就是6月24日——南希·厄普代克在伊拉克四处打电话寻找答案。
I called about a dozen people in different parts of the country, and I found out that that's also what they themselves were doing-- calling friends in other parts of Iraq to try and get some sense of what is going on where. Because what's happening to Iraqis right now is very different depending on where they are.
我给全国不同地区的大约十几个人打了电话，我发现这也是他们自己正在做的事情——给伊拉克其他地区的朋友打电话，试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。因为伊拉克人现在所经历的事情在很大程度上取决于他们身处何处。
Hello?
喂？
Hello, Joe Amir, it's Nancy.
喂，乔·阿米尔，我是南希。
Yes, Nancy. You called in a very good time. I'm just about to get into my car for someone else.
是的，南希。你打来的时间正好。我正准备上车。
Oh, great.
哦，太好了。
OK. Hold on.
好的。等一下。
This is Joe Amir Dzay. For years, he worked for an American NGO that dealt with land mines in Iraq.
这是乔·阿米尔·扎伊。多年来，他一直为一家处理伊拉克地雷问题的美国非政府组织工作。
Now it says hands free, so I can talk and  drive.
现在是免提的，所以我可以边开车边聊。
He lives in Erbil. It's a city in the north, the part of Iraq that's governed by the Kurds. They have their own very tough security force called the Peshmerga who've been keeping Erbil safe.
他住在埃尔比勒。那是北部的一个城市，伊拉克由库尔德人治理的部分。他们有自己非常强硬的安全部队，叫做“佩什梅格”，一直保护着埃尔比勒的安全。
If you tell your family, I am going to Erbil, It's in Iraq-- they will just cannot believe it.
如果你告诉你的家人，我要去埃尔比勒，在伊拉克——他们根本无法相信。
Right.
没错。
What? You are going to Iraq? Right?
什么？你要去伊拉克？对吧？
Right. Right.
没错，没错。
And you can't believe how safe is Erbil and how it is growing. I mean, I am driving now. This is bicycle rider. It seems like it's a bicycle race.
而且你无法相信埃尔比勒有多安全，发展得有多快。我的意思是，我正在开车。这是自行车骑手。看起来像是一场自行车比赛。
Oh, there's a bicycle race?
哦，有一场自行车比赛？
Yes. Two, four, six, 12-- 11 bicycle drivers. They are exactly in front of me now passing by.
是的。两辆、四辆、六辆、12辆——11名自行车手。他们正好在我前面经过。
[HONKING]
（鸣笛声）
OK. Just say hello to them. OK. No, no. Erbil is definitely safe.
好的。跟他们打个招呼。好吧。不，不。埃尔比勒绝对安全。
It's not unusual for a war or conflict to have pockets like this, where life is incongruously normal. But because Erbil and other Kurdish areas are safe at this point, they're also places that Iraqis and Syrians are fleeing to. The UN says, there are now an estimated 300,000 displaced people in the Kurdish region of the Iraq. Some are living in hotels or with families, but others are just sweltering in camps.
战争或冲突中有这样的口袋区域并不罕见，生活在这种环境中不和谐地正常。但因为埃尔比勒和其他库尔德地区目前是安全的，它们也是伊拉克人和叙利亚人逃难的地方。联合国称，目前估计有30万流离失所者在伊拉克的库尔德地区。有些人住在酒店或与亲戚住在一起，但其他人只是在营地里受热。
In these camps, they don't have air coolers. They don't have cold water. You know, all these people are in these camps. It's a disaster. Nancy, the temperature in Erbil-- it is 6:30 in the evening, and the temperature is 35 Celsius, I am talking about.
在这些营地里，他们没有冷风机。他们没有冷水。你知道，所有这些人都在这些营地里。这是一场灾难。南希，埃尔比勒的气温——现在是傍晚6:30，我说的气温是35摄氏度。
Yeah, 35 is-- I'm going to see what it is in Fahrenheit. Hold on. Yeah, it's 95 degrees Fahrenheit-- so very hot even though it's night.
是的，35是——我要看看华氏度是多少。等一下。是的，是95华氏度——所以即使是晚上也非常热。
No, no, no. Now it's very cool. For us, it's very cool. Now, now, this is the time when people come out for walking and you know, going for coffee and stuff like that. But in the noon time, it goes up to 44. Next month in the noon time, it goes up to 50, 5-0.
不，不，不。现在很凉快。对我们来说，这很凉快。现在是人们出来散步、喝咖啡之类的消遣时间。但在正午时分，它会升至44度。下个月在正午时分，它会升至50度，5-0。
That is 120 degrees. If you've ever been in a place that hot, you know it feels like being punched in the face. Joe Amir is Kurdish. He has two young kids, six and four years old. And for so many years, he and his wife worried that he might be killed for working for Americans, or just for being in the wrong place at the wrong time. Joe Amir says if there is no more Iraq, if it was chopped up into different countries, he really wouldn't miss it.
那是120华氏度。如果你曾经去过那么热的地方，你会知道那种感觉就像被拳头击中脸部。乔·阿米尔是库尔德人。他有两个年幼的孩子，六岁和四岁。多年来，他和妻子一直担心他可能会因为为美国人工作，或者仅仅是因为在错误的时间出现在错误的地点而被杀。乔·阿米尔说，如果伊拉克不再存在，如果它被拆分成不同的国家，他真的不会怀念它。
At least you have Kurdistan state. So whether it will be divided into four part, three part, or two part, we don't care, as long as there is Kurdistan state in place. Everybody, every Kurd will hope to have independent Kurdistan, really. I mean, nobody would like to stay any longer with Iraq.
至少你有库尔德斯坦国。所以无论它是被分成四个部分、三个部分，还是两个部分，我们都不在乎，只要有库尔德斯坦国存在。每个人，每个库尔德人都希望拥有独立的库尔德斯坦，真的。我的意思是，没有人愿意再和伊拉克呆在一起了。
About 60 miles west and a little north of Erbil is Mosul. That's the first city in Iraq that was invaded by ISIS, the Sunni militant group that's been fighting in Syria and now is in parts of Iraq. One of the other producers here called a man in Mosul, Ziad al-Sinjary. He's a stringer for different news outfits-- Reuters, the BBC. We reached him on June 19, nine days after ISIS took over the city.
在埃尔比勒以西偏北约60英里处是摩苏尔。那是伊拉克第一个被“伊斯兰国”入侵的城市，“伊斯兰国”是曾在叙利亚作战、现在在伊拉克部分地区活动的逊尼派激进组织。这里的另一位制作人给摩苏尔的一位男子打了个电话，叫齐亚德·辛贾里。他是不同新闻机构的撰稿人——路透社、英国广播公司。我们在6月19日联系到他，那是“伊斯兰国”接管该市九天后。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（外语演讲）
Actually, I went out today to do some shopping. I went to the center of Mosul. I bought some things from there. And I found that life is going on. Most of the markets are open. There's lots of food, vegetables, and the prices are against the expected. The prices have went down. We were expecting that it would go up.
事实上，我今天出去买东西了。我去了摩苏尔市中心。我在那里买了一些东西。我发现生活还在继续。大多数市场都开了。有很多食物、蔬菜，价格和预期的相反。价格下降了。我们原以为价格会上涨。
The Iraqi security forces who used to police Mosul are now all gone. They were mostly Shiite, and Ziad says plenty of the city's Sunni majority felt like, good riddance. When Ziad talks about ISIS, he calls them "the gunmen."
曾经在摩苏尔负责治安的伊拉克安全部队现在都走了。他们大多是什叶派，齐亚德说该市逊尼派多数居民觉得，终于摆脱他们了。当齐亚德谈到“伊斯兰国”时，他称他们为“枪手”。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（外语演讲）
Well, we know that the gunmen are supposed to be barbarians. But you can go anywhere. You can park anywhere. You can do whatever you want. And this is something strange. This is something that we weren't expecting.
嗯，我们知道枪手应该是野蛮人。但你可以去任何地方。你可以把车停在任何地方。你可以做任何你想做的事。这很奇怪。这是我们没预料到的。
Life in general, most of the roads in Mosul have been opened. The checkpoints have been removed. The concrete barriers that were there are removed. There is no violence. There is no shooting.
总的来说，摩苏尔的大多数道路已经开放。检查站已经被拆除。那里的混凝土路障也被拆除了。没有暴力。没有枪声。
That's how Ziad sees it. I reached another man in Mosul, a political science professor at the University there, who said, of course there's no violence, because it was ISIS who was doing the shooting and the bombing when they were attacking the Iraqi security forces. Now that they've driven the security forces out of the city, ISIS is running the place.
这就是齐亚德眼中的情况。我联系了摩苏尔的另一位男子，该大学的一位政治学教授，他说，当然没有暴力，因为在攻击伊拉克安全部队时，是“伊斯兰国”在开枪和炸弹袭击。现在他们把安全部队赶出了城市，“伊斯兰国”正在那里经营。
The professor said he's not going to work these days. Higher education isn't really functioning in the city. He said he's afraid of ISIS and what they'll do next.
教授说他这些天不去上班了。高等教育在该市并没有真正发挥作用。他说他害怕“伊斯兰国”以及他们下一步会做什么。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
（外语演讲）
ISIS have distributed their symbol to each and every mosque. There's no mosque operating in the city without their logo basically on the gate and inside where the preacher stands. Their messages are that first we are in a transitional state. As soon as we establish the fundamentals of the Islamic state, things are going to be different. We are coming to relieve the city of the forces of evil, meaning the Iraqi state forces, the Shiites.
“伊斯兰国”已经把他们的标志分发到每一座清真寺。没有哪座清真寺不在大门上印有他们的标志，在传教士站立的地方内部也一样。他们的信息是，首先我们处于过渡状态。一旦我们建立了伊斯兰国家的基本原则，情况就会不同。我们是为了从邪恶势力——意指伊拉克国家部队、什叶派——手中解救这座城市。
The city itself is in deep slumber. It's terrified, and fear is all around. Currently there are no assassinations and killings, but people are still afraid because they know how ISIS operates. They know that it's only a matter of time and that ISIS is now being so nice only because they want to win people over. For the people of Mosul, there's no other solution now other than being quiet and sitting at home and waiting for the worst thing to happen.
城市本身陷入了沉睡。它很害怕，恐惧无处不在。目前没有暗杀和杀戮，但人们仍然害怕，因为他们知道“伊斯兰国”是如何运作的。他们知道这只是时间问题，“伊斯兰国”现在表现得如此友好只是因为他们想赢得民心。对于摩苏尔的人民来说，现在除了安静地呆在家里等待最坏的事情发生之外，没有其他解决办法。
In Baghdad, I called another professor, a professor of linguistics, Mohammed. He is going to work. He said he was shocked when ISIS went into Mosul and worried. But he says now he's not that worried. He's Shia in a city, Baghdad, that's majority Shia.
在巴格达，我给另一位教授打了电话，一位语言学教授，穆罕默德。他要去上班。他说当“伊斯兰国”进入摩苏尔时，他很震惊并感到担忧。但他说他现在没那么担心了。他是什叶派，身处一个以什叶派为主的城市——巴格达。
The first time I interviewed Mohammed was four years ago, just before the US officially ended its combat mission in Iraq. And he told me at the time about going to lunch with a Sunni friend. Again, Mohammed is Shia. And the friend told him casually over lunch, when the Americans leave, we-- the Sunni resistance-- we are going to take back the country.
我第一次采访穆罕默德是在四年前，就在美国正式结束在伊拉克的作战任务之前。当时他告诉我他和一个逊尼派朋友去吃午餐。再说一次，穆罕默德是什叶派。那位朋友在午餐时随意地告诉他，当美国人离开时，我们——逊尼派抵抗力量——我们将夺回国家。
And after telling that story, Mohammed talked about Shia-Sunni tensions in Iraq generally. This was back in 2010. And I called him now, because I wanted to ask him something, which is, in the United States, what we hear about Iraq and the fighting is that it's all sectarian. It's Sunni versus Shia. ISIS and the other groups that are fighting with them are Sunni. The prime minister, Shia. The militias driving around Baghdad, Shia-- and so on, and so on.
讲完那个故事后，穆罕默德谈到了伊拉克普遍存在的什叶派和逊尼派紧张局势。那是在2010年。我现在给他打电话，因为我想问他一件事，那就是在美国，我们听到的关于伊拉克和战斗的消息都是教派之争。逊尼派对抗什叶派。“伊斯兰国”和与他们并肩作战的其他组织是逊尼派。总理是什叶派。在巴格达四处出没的民兵是什叶派——等等，等等。
But when I've talked to Iraqis over the last 10 years-- and this is my experience, but other reporters have also told me they get this-- if I ask an Iraqi, are you Sunni or Shia, their answer is often an annoyed, why are you asking me that? That's not how I think about things. I'm Iraqi. So I asked the professor, what's going on? And his take was, of course they say that-- in public.
但当我在过去10年里与伊拉克人交谈时——这是我的经验，但其他记者也告诉我说他们有这种感觉——如果我问一个伊拉克人，你是逊尼派还是什叶派，他们的回答通常是恼火地反问，你为什么问这个？我不是那样想事情的。我是伊拉克人。所以我问教授，发生了什么事？他的看法是，他们当然会那样说——在公开场合。
But deep inside, they are all defending their sectarian identity. And when they are at home, they will teach their children how to hate Shia. And Shias, they teach  them how to hate Sunnis. In fact, somebody said it, that sectarians is like adultery. All are denouncing publicly, but all are, you know-- let's just say--
但内心深处，他们都在捍卫自己的教派身份。当他们在家里时，他们会教导孩子如何憎恨什叶派。而什叶派，他们教导他们如何憎恨逊尼派。事实上，有人说，教派主义就像通奸。所有人都公开谴责，但所有人都，你知道——我们还是说——
People denounce it in public, and then they just do it behind [INAUDIBLE]?
人们在公开场合谴责它，然后他们在[音频模糊]后面做它？
Yes. Everyone is doing it. Everyone is sectarian, actually. Now, look at the social network, the Facebook pages. Because many people have their imitation names, have their Sunni names, so they will speak it freely against the Shiites. And the Shiites will speak it freely against the Sunnis. In the morning, we'll say, no, there is no difference between Shias and Sunnis. We are all Iraqis. So this is why when you ask somebody, OK, are you Sunni or Shia, they say, no, please don't ask me. I am Iraqi.
是的。每个人都在做。每个人实际上都是教派主义者。现在，看看社交网络，Facebook页面。因为许多人使用化名，有他们的逊尼派名字，所以他们会自由地反对什叶派。什叶派也会自由地反对逊尼派。早上，我们会说，不，什叶派和逊尼派之间没有区别。我们都是伊拉克人。这就是为什么当你问某人，好的，你是逊尼派还是什叶派，他们会说，不，请别问我。我是伊拉克人。
I mean, all of these things that you're saying, is this what you think, you personally, when you go to University, you talk against sectarianism if anyone brings it up. But when you get home, when you're private, you're like, this is the way it is, is that true for you, personally?
我的意思是，你说的所有这些，这就是你的想法吗，你自己，当你去大学时，如果有人提起，你反对教派主义。但当你回到家，当你是私下里，你就会说，情况就是这样，这对你个人来说是真的吗？
Yes. Yes, actually. It's the truth. I myself do it. Yes. Yeah. Frankly speaking. I'm going to be frank with you.
是的。是的，实际上。这是事实。我自己也这样做。是的。是的。坦率地说。我要对你坦白。
Yeah.
是的。
Nancy, hello?
南希，喂？
I'm here.
我在。
Nancy?
南希？
I'm here. I'm here. Can  you hear me?
我在。我在。你能听到我说话吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I told you, yes.
是的。是的，我告诉过你，是的。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, hi, Nancy.
哦，嗨，南希。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good. I'm good. I'm good.
我很好。我很好。我很好。
This is the last call I'm going to play for you. Talal Ajeel-- he's near Basra, way in the south of Iraq, a seven-plus hour drive from Baghdad. Talal used to work for USAID. Now he works for an oil company in the south. But his family-- his wife and his five-year-old daughter-- are back in Baghdad.
这是我准备为你播放的最后一个电话。塔拉勒·阿吉尔——他在伊拉克南部的巴士拉附近，离巴格达有七个多小时的车程。塔拉勒过去为美国国际开发署工作。现在他在南部的一家石油公司工作。但他的家人——他的妻子和五岁的女儿——都在巴格达。
His daughter, when this crisis started, stopped going to kindergarten. And his wife has taken her vacation so that she can just sit tight at home with their daughter and see how things play out in the next few weeks. Talal is Shia, but he's secular. And he lives in a neighborhood that used to be mixed-- Sunni, Shia, Kurd-- and then became mostly Sunni after the sectarian fighting in Baghdad during the Iraq War. Talal and I talked a couple of times. This call was at night after he got off work.
当这场危机开始时，他的女儿停止了上幼儿园。他的妻子休了假，这样她就可以带着女儿待在家里，看看未来几周情况会如何发展。塔拉勒是什叶派，但他是世俗主义者。他住在一个曾经是混合社区的地方——逊尼派、什叶派、库尔德人——然后在伊拉克战争期间巴格达发生教派冲突后，它变成了以逊尼派为主。塔拉勒和我谈过几次。这个电话是在他下班后的晚上打的。
You know, Nancy, the common issue that you hear from all Iraqis is that we don't want to divide Iraq into three countries-- Kurd, Sunni, Shia. This is a nightmare for us. And today I heard that this might be happening.
你知道，南希，你从所有伊拉克人那里听到的共同问题是，我们不想把伊拉克分成三个国家——库尔德、逊尼、什叶。这对我们来说是一场噩梦。今天我听说这可能会发生。
Where did you hear it?
你从哪里听说的？
In the company we were talking. We were a few Iraqis, you know, talking to each other. And some of the Iraqis, they made this point. I mean, we're going to divide Iraq into Kurd, Sunni, Shia. [INAUDIBLE] they want their region.
在公司里我们谈论的时候。我们是几个伊拉克人，你知道，在互相交谈。一些伊拉克人提出了这一点。我的意思是，我们要把伊拉克分成库尔德、逊尼、什叶。他们想要他们的地区。
They would be happy if it's divided, and they would just keep the south?
如果它被分开了，他们会很高兴，他们会只保留南部？
Yeah. In Basra, yes.
是的。在巴士拉，是的。
I mean, they have all the oil. Or a lot of it.
我的意思是，他们拥有所有的石油。或者很大一部分。
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, lots of people in Basra, they said, OK, [INAUDIBLE]. We don't need Baghdad. We don't need [INAUDIBLE]. We don't need Kurds. Have our own region. This is a nightmare. I mean, is this the new Iraq?
是的，是的。是的，巴士拉的许多人说，好的。我们不需要巴格达。我们不需要[音频模糊]。我们不需要库尔德人。拥有我们自己的地区。这是一场噩梦。我的意思是，这是新的伊拉克吗？
If it was divided that way, Sunnis in the north, Shia in the south, and then Kurdistan, where would you live?
如果是那样划分的话，北部的逊尼派，南部的什叶派，然后是库尔德斯坦，你会住在哪里？
I don't know. I don't have any other place to live. I cannot live with Sunnis. I cannot live with Shia. I cannot live with Kurds. I think we're going to be homeless or something  like that. I don't know. It's a nightmare.
我不知道。我没有任何其他地方可住。我不能和逊尼派住在一起。我不能和什叶派住在一起。我不能和库尔德人住在一起。我想我们要么无家可归，要么类似的事情。我不知道。这是一场噩梦。
In case this isn't clear, or course Talal could live with Shias. He's Shia. But the point is that he doesn't want to live in a sectarian, one-horse country or city. He wants to live in Iraq. He wants his daughter to be Iraqi. He wants to live in a neighborhood like they used to live in.
以防这还不清楚，塔拉勒当然可以和什叶派一起生活。他是什叶派。但重点是他不想生活在一个教派主义的、一国一制的国家或城市。他想住在伊拉克。他想让他的女儿成为伊拉克人。他想住在他以前住的那种社区里。
Talking to Talal, I kept thinking about Yugoslavia-- this country that existed for decades and then just didn't. Suddenly you couldn't be Yugoslavian anymore. You had to go be with your own kind, which was whatever the guys with guns decided it was.
和塔拉勒交谈，我不停地想到南斯拉夫——这个存在了几十年然后就消失了的国家。突然之间你不能再当南斯拉夫人了。你必须去和你的同类在一起，而那类人是由拿枪的人决定的。
So anyway, Nancy, it's not good. I mean, I don't know if the United States is feeling that-- maybe you can answer this question.
所以，总之，南希，情况不好。我的意思是，我不知道美国是否感觉到了——也许你可以回答这个问题。
I doubt it, but go ahead.
我很怀疑，但请继续。
[CHUCKLING] All right. All right. I got you. Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]. Now we're in the middle. We cannot go back where we started and fix this. We cannot go any further. Every group is caring only about himself or his people.
（笑声）好的。好的。我明白了。是的。[音频模糊]。现在我们在中间。我们不能回到我们开始的地方来解决这个问题。我们不能再进一步了。每个群体只关心他自己或他自己的人民。
And at the end of this, we're going to divide Iraq. I mean, I used to have a country. That's how I feel right now. I used to have a country. Another checkpoint.
而在这一切结束时，我们将分裂伊拉克。我的意思是，我曾经有一个国家。这就是我现在的感受。我曾经有一个国家。又一个检查站。
Police checkpoint?
警察检查站？
It's a police checkpoint.
这是一个警察检查站。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC -  "IS EVERYTHING HAPPENING UNCONTROLLABLY" BY  BILL EAST]
（音乐 - 比尔·伊斯特的“一切都在无法控制地发生”）
Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrienne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
好吧，我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自艾莉森·戴维斯。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安·马蒂奥维兹管理我们的网站。研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
And special thanks to Becca Heller and the Iraqi Refugee Assistance Project. They're helping hundreds of Iraqis try to escape the violence and get to safety in the United States. Their website is refugeerights.org. And to Kirk Johnson and The List Project. Regular listeners to our show know they help Iraqis who worked for the United States and are now in danger because of it get to safety. Their website is thelistproject.org. Both of these organizations have been flooded with emails in the last two weeks from people needing help.
特别感谢贝卡·海勒和伊拉克难民援助项目。他们正在帮助数百名伊拉克人逃离暴力，并安全抵达美国。他们的网站是refugeerights.org。还要感谢柯克·约翰逊和名单项目。我们节目的常规听众知道，他们帮助那些为美国工作、现在因此处于危险中的伊拉克人获得安全。他们的网站是thelistproject.org。过去两周，这两个组织都淹没在需要帮助的人发来的电子邮件中。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International-- this week for the last week. They've been our partner for 17 years, and they've been a great partner, and we wish them the best. Thanks as always to Torey Malatia. You know, at the beginning of this show, when we started This American Life together, even then, he already wanted to disavow any responsibility for what happens here each week. He told me--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发——这是本周最后一周。他们与我们合作了17年，他们一直是一个伟大的合作伙伴，我们祝愿他们一切顺利。一如既往地感谢托雷·马拉蒂亚。你知道，在这个节目开始时，当我们一起创办《美国生活》时，即使在那时，他也已经想否认对每周在这里发生的事情承担任何责任。他告诉我——
This is what I'm going to do. You're going to run the show, but you will now hypnotize me, and I will forget.
这是我要做的。你将负责节目，但你现在要催眠我，我会忘记。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。